did you see the story from l.a times and
all over the place whether vladimir
putin is terminally ill and dying of
cancer
a former russian intelligence officer
and others believe so did you see that
story i didn't see it
and i believe it when vladimir dies from
cancer okay so you think that's another
story that's being made out of yeah one
on one reason why many people think in
uh uh russian president vladimir putin
has executed executed the invasion of
ukraine so quickly and suddenly he's
dying according to reports citing a
former russian intelligence officer who
now
works for the pentagon putin could be
suffering from terminal
bowel cancer his puffy face seen in
images this year could indicate he is
undergoing chemotherapy treatments on
steroids the daily star reported
this in their story that quoted the
source the source says this diagnosis
could have encouraged him to be more
aggressive and attack ukraine so he can
leave a legacy knowing he is dying he
added that analysis have been studying
putin who think he has a terminal
illness
and here's another source quoted from
the daily start in the past
we've seen him smile but in 2022 there
are a few pictures of him looking happy
his look suggests he is in pain and our
people suggest his angry look is most
likely as a result of being in agony or
people are confident he is ill he is
concerned about covet as he keeps his
staff as a at a distance
uh
how much credibility you think there's
behind this
uh
none i mean i mean how would you ever
even
so so this guy the ex-intelligence agent
is a doctor a medical doctor he can you
can see this and i i could i could
understand that
vladimir doesn't sleep very well these
days works really hard so that shows in
your face and
this is just wishful thinking and you're
muddling the picture
just you got to deal with what you know
is the truth well remember when they did
this with kim jong-un for like a couple
months they were like yeah he's sick
we found his twin it's not really a
strategy he's gaining weight he's got
the gap what is the strategy
to do what oh it's just the story you're
saying it's just to get views
okay no but what i'm saying is why is a
intelligence guy that now works at a
pentagon what is his motive to release
that not not media he's not trying to do
clickbait what's his motive to get his
name out i mean how big of how big of an
official i would be so upset if you were
working for me i'm like what the hell
are you doing
what are you doing to get your name out
you think this is one of the best things
that chief disguise officer ci agent
jonah mendes told me she said the best
qualities about a ci agency intelligence
agents is what you're charming you're
charismatic you're this you're that
you're this you're handsome you're a
great salesman but when you save the
world from world war three you don't
tell anybody about it because you don't
need the recognition she said that's the
quality don't be an intelligence
character by the way i get it but we
have all those great qualities and don't
tell anybody my question would be is how
high ranking is the official
i mean remember anonymous that was
supposed to be this super high ranking
trump official that wrote the big paper
back in what 2017. you saw anonymous
came out the other day right he was a
low-level staffer that nobody knew i i
would venture to say it's similar with
this guy so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]